ah the 20th day of April it's springtime
and there's just something in the air
what have you call it
we the chronic the stickiest of the icky
this is a day of celebration and
probably snacking breathe it in with
apps that'll take your hi to the next
level as long as you're not bringing any
laws obviously first you'll need to know
where to find the good stuff
legally in weed maps are your best buds
weed maps fines reviews dispensaries
doctors and delivery services near you
we flee similar only it lets you search
for a particular strain in pinpointer
dispensary that carries it and please if
you appreciate those notes of pine and
elderberry leave a review even if you
aren't sure what strain is best for you
Leafly lets you search for one that's
just right what do you get when you mix
tinder and reefer doobie lets you upload
your pictures of all things we called
doobies users then swipe right to pass a
doobie on or left to put the doobie out
we see what you did there
doobie need a place to post pics of your
beloved weed and weed related activities
massroots has you covered think of it
like Instagram only with a whole lot
more pot a lot more pot just a funny
guess but you're probably hungry by this
point if only there were a way to order
food by lifting one finger enter
seamless just find what you're craving
place your order and wait for the
doorbell to ring not a bad way to spend
this most heady of days so snooty boo
cheese my friends snooty boo cheese